I know you said sometimes you you only
get one shot with these people in the
rare instance that you actually get to
come back I noticed for me interviewing
someone the first day they're usually
pitch mode and they're kind of on their
best behavior and they're sort of in
this is me and they love to tell you
more about themselves and then when you
come back the next time I notice they're
actually more real and for me I found
that that sometimes the best time to
capture them so how do you deal with
that when someone's in super pitch mode
and you you kind of want them to be a
little more real and you feel that
they're almost putting on either happy
after the camera or whatever it is that
they think you want to see how do you
kind of ground them back to who they are
well reason the way I personally deal
with someone being in pitch mode and
kind of presenting a front the first
time I meet them is I don't meet them
the first time I like the producers talk
to him on the phone and and my producers
are so good they do it for reality TV
that they know that just let the person
talk for like an hour an hour and a half
tell you their whole story and that gets
rid of their kind of this is me this is
who I want to be presented as in the
world so to speak so when I show up I
hadn't really even talked to them and i
said like i said i'm talking to him
about their house i'm talking to him
about all the way you do for fun and
it's completely like I'm not even
involved in a way in a very symbolic way
with the documentary I'm just somebody
showing up at their house if that makes
sense so that's the way I basically get
around a false front of people is to let
somebody else have the false front and
then I get the real person you're the
closer the closer yeah I'm the you know
and I let the producers talk about all
the documentary stuff of terms oh yeah
the interview is going to be two hours
and you know we'll take 30 minutes to
set up you do you know you can you sign
your release now sort of things so I let
them take care of anything that really
reflects a movie and of course we shoot
with like the DSLRs to on our dogs so a
lot of people who aren't really familiar
with the film industry because they're
just random documentary subjects it's
much
more comforting to shoot with a still
camera than with a big giant camera and
a boom mic and all that I always lapel
the documentary subjects and I do that
when I'm the first thing before I'm even
setting up and I turn the audio on
before I even pull out the camera just
in case they you know they want to tell
me their story right away at least i
have it on audio but then you know after
10 minutes they forget that they had the
mic on and you know make it as as
unobtrusive for them or a show that
we're shooting a movie for them as
possible whether it's just like oh I'm
just talking to this tall ginger guy who
walked in my door for some reason what
about when you show up and you just see
it on them that today is not the day
yeah whatever maybe they got a phone
call about their credit card payment
before you showed up whatever it is and
you just go I don't think today's a day
and you try to get them out of that
space in their head where they're
thinking about something else if I show
up and they have the appearance of
today's not the day and they're
depressed because they have a credit
card payment or whatnot to me that's
actually kind of a good thing because I
like variety and you know and you know
documentary documentary narts
necessarily real in a sense that's your
it's still your objection of you point
of something even if you're trying to
make the most verte documentary ever
it's still going to be your very point
and still going to be that subject on
that day or if their person assigned of
a false front whatever they want to
present and how you get past that so to
me having someone who's say depressed or
angry for some other reason it's just
it's fine because I think people kind of
intuitively know that if they're you
know through subconscious means of you
know body language and what not and also
I like the variety of of a another doc
we're doing is it has people in
different stages of their lives and
their you know they have different views
of how their older people and they have
different view
of how they feel about their life that
they lived and I'm you know that's great
for me that's that's like a gumbo you
know it's it's a mix of a whole bunch of
ingredients that make a movie no movie
you don't want to release in my opinion
don't want to have a one-tonne kind of
movie you want to have anger and sadness
and all that stuff so I actually don't
mind that at all the kind of concept
you